it's a historic moment for the United
States the first time a criminal former
president has ever been federally
indicted for breaking the laws of the
United States what we can expect to see
on Tuesday at Donald Trump's first court
appearance which is called the
arraignment he will voluntarily turn
himself into the local FBI field office
in the southern district of Florida he
will be processed like every other
arrestee he will be fingerprinted he
will have his arrest photo taken and
then he will be transported to court
where he'll make his first court
appearance the indictment will be read
he will enter a plea presumably if not
guilty he'll turn their attention to
what conditions of release the judge
might set for Donald Trump then they
will pick a next court date I don't
suspect we will have a trial date set
but for people who are interested a rule
of thumb is you can probably expect this
case to go to trial in about one year
which would put us in the summer of 2024
as we are in the run-up to the November
presidential election so it does feel
like time is of the essence to get this
case tried and resolved